Hí zinh khó có bộ đổi 2 quân khó chỉ vẫn tài xung nơi đầu sống hoặc gió,
những người liên bình bùng bốn thôn này đã khoác lên mình mộ áo thật,
mà theo bố, kiên và bầu miếng tế với bạc quan tùng lũ khánh hoạc đặc lắc.
Sáng 1 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 3
chỉ dịch quan trung chính thức phát động với tình thần thân tốc.
Theo kế hoạc bộ bốn 2 quân sẽ phối hợp với bộ chỉ vì quân sự tình khánh hoạc.
Đặc lắc thì là bố miế đội thật, bố đội từ 12.000 mấy đồng chi.
Các đội thật sẽ vụng được lượng cá mộ, chỉ dịch có tình nghề xe dự,
cơ khi, mọc, đến nước, cộng với phương tệ trong vị của đối bị.
Một tiêu, dự lại mại ấm, sự chứ hứa 2 cho bà con,
thơi hạ, khoản thành trước ngày 3 mốt tháng 1 năm ngày hành hủ trăm hà nè sấu.
Đây không chỉ là những vụ, mà là tình cảm quân dân cà nước,
để bà con sơm ăn cơ, đến nước kười lại nổi trên những vùng đất vừa trải qua bà lũ,
những người nhà mối xe sơ mọc lên trước chắn và ấm áp nghĩa tình.
Bốn tiên nhé, các anh đã để dồi.